>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Good afternoon, my name is
Georgette Dorn and I'm the chief
of the Hispanic division.
It is an enormous
honor and pleasure
to welcome here his Excellency
ambassador Camilo Reyes
of Colombia and I want to thank
the ambassador to have organized
and thought about
this wonderful salute
to Colombia the whole
week here in Washington.
I also want to thank
Catalina Gómez
who has actually gathered
these incredible treasures
which have never seen by the
public so these are treasures
that the public doesn't
generally see.
I also want to thank the
maison [phonetic] division,
the prison photo division,
the geography map division
and the red book room
for lending us these precious
materials that nobody sees.
And I also want to welcome
here, Mrs. Arbeláez ,
the wife of Fernando Arbeláez,
to whom we have to thank
that we were able to record
Gabriel García Márquez
for the arcade, so its
so nice to see her too.
Thank you.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Buenas tardes,
muchísimas gracias Georgette,
muchísimas gracias Catalina,
muchísimas gracias la
Doctora Claudia Navas,
muchísimas gracias a todos
ustedes por estar aquí hoy.
Esta de verdad es una
ocasión extraordinaria.
Cuando vemos la colección de
documentos, de mapas, de libros,
de objetos artísticos,
porque incluye mucha pintura que
pertenece a la biblioteca del
congreso de los Estados Unidos
de América sobre nuestro país,
sobre Colombia.
Yo quiero agradecer
particularmente el trabajo que
han adelantado ustedes,
Georgette, Catalina,
muchísimas gracias, Gladys
por pensar en este evento,
pero más que en el evento en
traer a la realidad diaria una
riqueza enorme para Colombia que
debemos de aprender a aprovechar
en una mucha mejor forma.
Aquí, a juzgar por la
lista que me mostró Gladys,
Gladys me trajo una lista hace
como tres semanas y me dijo,
mire embajador, esta es una
lista que no es exhaustiva pero
es una lista de algunos de los
documentos y los libros que
reposan en la biblioteca de el
congreso de los Estados Unidos
de América para que usted
escoja qué queremos exponer.
Y yo realmente quedé
muy sorprendido,
no sólo de la variedad, de
la riqueza de la colección,
de la forma como cubre
nuestra historia,
porque aquí hay
documentos precolombinos,
aquí hay documentos que
obedecen a los tiempos de la
conquista, reflejan los
tiempos de la conquista,
fueron hechos durante
la conquista.
Hay documentos de la Colonia,
hay documentos de la
guerra de independencia
realmente interesantísimos.
Cartas del libertador,
cartas del General Santander y
una gran variedad de literatura
de los siglos 17, 18 y
19 incluido el siglo 20.
Están libros de
García Márquez,
están libros de Álvaro Mutis.
Acabo de ver una belleza de
texto ilustrado por el famoso
pintor, maravilloso pintor
colombiano David Manzur y con
estos de Juan Gustavo Cobo
Borda, realmente son tesoros.
Entonces estamos desenterrando
un tesoro colombiano,
lo digo con humildad, yo llevo
ya aquí algunos meses y la
verdad es que debía de
tener en mi actividad,
venir aquí frecuentemente y
aprovechar esta cantidad de
sabiduría que hay para
ver mejor, más cerca,
en mejor forma, nuestro
propio país.
Estaba comentando antes,
de que tuviera la oportunidad
de dirigirme a ustedes que sólo
entre ayer y hoy a uno se le
ocurren varias propuestas para
Colombia, entre otras cosas
que se aumente la capacidad
colombiana en Estados Unidos,
porque deberíamos de tener
gente permanente aprovechando e
investigando desde el punto de
vista histórico esta cantidad
de documentos y esta cantidad
de recursos que presenta esta
gran biblioteca.
Es probable que esta
sea la biblioteca,
una de las bibliotecas
más ricas sobre Colombia,
esa es una realidad.
Pensaba ayer que tuvimos una
reunión muy interesante en el
Smithsonian Institute, que esa
es otra área de trabajo que
tenemos que lograr desarrollar.
Estuvimos allá con
compañeros de la embajada,
con el Doctor Jorge Andrés
Osorio que está aquí,
y estamos pensando en
lograr suscribir un MOU,
o memorándum de entendimiento
para desarrollar un proyecto de
trabajo conjunto entre Colombia
y el Smithsonian Institute para
la preservación de la riqueza
de biodiversidad en Colombia.
Y deberíamos hacer otro
tanto acá Georgette,
voy a hacer un esfuerzo para
proponerles a ustedes un
programa de trabajo con
esta bellísima biblioteca.
Yo sé que ya hay
investigadores aquí,
como es el caso de Catalina,
ya hay colombianos que están
involucrados en investigar acá,
pero el gobierno colombiano,
el ministerio de educación,
el ministerio de cultura,
debería ser protagonista en
la creación de un vínculo
especial para asegurar que
aprovechemos este tesoro que hay
acá, este tesoro
de conocimiento,
este tesoro histórico,
este tesoro que se extiende a
la proyección de Colombia hacia
el futuro.
Hace muy poco leí un bellísimo
libro de un gran historiador
americano que se
llama David McCulloch,
quien en una de sus
presentaciones en una
universidad decía que el
conocimiento de la historia le
da una dimensión distinta a la
vida de una persona y que cuando
la gente se involucra
en la historia,
adquiere la capacidad de
vivir unas vidas extras,
de reincorporar el pasado pero
sobre todo de imaginar con más
precisión, con más ilusión,
con más optimismo y con
más información el futuro.
Yo creo que esta es una
oportunidad que nos permitirá
hacer eso para Colombia.
De nuevo, muchísimas
gracias Georgette,
es un placer haberla conocido
personalmente y estar aquí en
ésta su casa, su emporio.
Muchísimas gracias Catalina,
de nuevo gracias a Gladys
por haber organizado esto y
muchísimas gracias a todos
ustedes por estar presentes hoy
acá, lo importante
es que volvamos.
Gracias.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov